hello my name is viktoria Mizuki and I'm  the manager at rats  this week is national volunteers week  and opportunities say thank you to all  those people who freely give up their  time for voluntary and community groups  in the Rochford district most of the  time this work is unrecognized but  during the current situation we have  seen these volunteers adapt to new ways  of working demonstrate their flexibility  to ensure their group members are always  supported whether you volunteer on a  regular basis or ad hoc you are making a  real difference to people's lives  the Rochford community response app has  shown how quickly people have responded  to support those in their communities  the landscape of voluntary and community  groups is changing and people are  changing with them if you are interested  in volunteering or a local group is in  need of volunteers then please get in  touch with Brad's thank you guys